des experts des scientifiques des
économistes à l'invitation du pacte pour
la transition propose sans une idée pour
une relance verte est juste et parmi les
idées des chantiers régionaux de
transition un conseil national de
transition pour aller choisir des
projets qui répondent aux objectifs
d'une économie viable et un super fond
de la transition
l'économiste françois delorme à
travailler aux propositions phares de ce
document françois delorme bonsoir
bonsoir jura alors d'abord le
gouvernement du québec dit aujourd'hui
et on entendait monsieur dubé en parler
on est en crise il faut accélérer les
projets il faut accélérer des
autorisations environnementales
également notamment
alors pensez vous que vos propositions
cadre vraiment dans cette idée qu'a le
gouvernement d'accélérer la reprise
économique
je pense que nos propositions cadre dans
une certaine reprise économique qui est
un plan de relance comme on l'a baptisé
vert est juste et je pense que c'est
important d'orienter nos efforts en ce
sens on veut pas retourner à l'ancien
modèle économique un e ronde des
exigences au niveau climatique qui sont
prépondérantes
alors c'est sûr que nous ce qu'on
propose laissant une initiative
s'inscrit dans un axe de développement
économique qui est un des quelque chose
de contemporain qui répond aux exigences
de la lutte aux changements climatiques
ouais mais le gouvernement doit faire
des choix en ce moment pendant qu'il ya
des gens qui sont au chômage et son
objectif affiché c'est de revenir aussi
l équilibre budgétaire d'ici trois à
cinq ans est-ce que les efforts de
transition et le et écologique selon
vous pourrait être largement réduit
justement par les effets de la crise
mais c'est des arbitrages qui sont
intéressants je pense que la lutte aux
changements climatiques demande d'avoir
une focale de perspectives un peu plus à
moyen terme et je comprends très bien
que le gouvernement
revenir en tout cas c'est ce que le
ministre nous dit de revenir rapidement
de 3 à 5 ans avec lille budgétaire mais
je ne pense pas que ça soit nécessaire
je pense que le gouvernement sincèrement
se trompe de dette
je pense que on a à peu près aujourd'hui
on nous dit qu'on a un déficit de 15
milliards qui équivaut à peu près à
trois points 5 % du pib le gouvernement
de l'équilibré budgétaire donc amené la
tête à une sur une trajectoire
descendante
oui d'ailleurs un jouet d'engager que
vous avez préparé à l'antenne exactement
donc on voit que la cible et qui était
prévu à 20 la crise pandémique
car on mesure de la dette par les
déficits cumulés l'accumulation où
l'accumulation des déficits étaient 17%
avec la crise qu'on pandémique mais
calcule non pas à peu près le construit
autour de 20%
donc rien de vraiment d'alarmant à ce
niveau là si on décide de ramener le
déficit à zéro et donc de diminuer la
dette ça veut dire que ça nous empêche
d'investir de façon colossale est
important dans la lutte à la transition
écologique et donc c'est une autre dette
qu'on va léguer aux générations futures
à nos enfants nos petits-enfants en ait
200 pas aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
c'est eux qui vont pâtir de cette
situation l'un et qu'on va leur léguer
un environnement qui est malsain et
toxique alors je pense que quand je dis
que le gouvernement se trompe de dettes
c'est que je suis un partisan de la
consolidation budgétaire mais je pense
que l'objectif de ramener le déficit à
zéro dans une personnalité de 3 à 5 ans
et il est approprié
c'est trop rapide c'est trop rapide et
je ne voudrais pas qu'on reconnaître
l'erreur qu'on a fait en 2015 2016 où le
gouvernement s'est engagé dans une
période d'austérité a pour les mêmes
motifs
pour les mêmes raisons et on arrive à
quoi aujourd'hui on arrive à des soins
aux aînés qui sont dites
un des chs elle dit ou encore on est
obligé de gérer en catastrophe et je
pense que c'est un résultat de notre
notre mauvaise gestion si vous voulez en
2015 2016 avant on arrive exactement à
la même chose aujourd'hui par rapport au
vieillissement
c'est pas le temps de désinvestir quand
on va avoir une proportion importante de
nos amis dans l'est dans les prochaines
années qui vont présenter la proportion
de la population et c'est la même chose
pour la lutte aux changements
climatiques
la dette financière est la dette
environnementale ses deux demis qui
n'encourt pas du même besoin au niveau
de l'iniquité intergénérationnel et donc
vous proposer font un super fonds pour
la transition qui serait alimenté par
des obligations vertes des obligations
de la victoire mais vraiment de
l'endettement du gouvernement mais dédié
en fait les sommes seraient dédiés
véritablement à la transition écologique
en quoi c'est différent de ce qui existe
déjà quand on pense au fond vert par
exemple je dis je pense que il ya
plusieurs choses nous laissant une
proposition que l'on fait touche le
transport et l'industrie le bâtiment
l'agriculture mais une des propositions
importantes c'est comment est-ce qu'on
va financer ça et là super fonds de
transition les obligations vertes ce
serait des obligations qui seraient
spécifiquement dédié à la transition
écologique donc à ce moment-là ça que ça
correspond aux besoins de financement du
gouvernement avec le même niveau de
reddition de comptes et d'imputabilité
c'est juste que ces fonds là sont dédiés
à la transition écologique et serait
donc investi dans des projets pour
lesquels il y aurait de reddition de
comptes au niveau de la lutte aux
changements climatiques et à la
diminution de la croissance des jeux s
ou la réduction des germes et françois
delorme et ce qui n'existe pas déjà le
fonds vert qui accueille cette fonction
de dédier des sommes à des à des projets
verts mais gérard c'est vrai mais la
dernière vente aux enchères demi a
montré qu'il ya seulement 6 37 pour
100 des crédits carbone qui ont été
achetés ont distrait pourquoi parce que
l'activité économique a été réduite et
tout donner ce que ça veut dire c'est
que dans la lutte aux changements
climatiques
il ya les deux tiers des fonds qui
devaient financer cette lutte aux
changements climatiques qui devait
provenir du fonds vert alors ce que ça
veut dire c'est que il va avoir besoin
de ressources supplémentaires pour
financer la lutte aux changements
climatiques puisque le fonds vert ne
soit pas suffisant et c'est dans cette
optique le que s'inscrit le superflu de
transition au niveau des obligations
ouverte et je pense que c'est tout il
devient extrêmement important pour
pallier à l'insuffisance des
financements du fonds vert merci
beaucoup françois delorme
merci beaucoup gerra